القتال شرس للغاية والنصر
مرير للغاية ولم يتبق سوى القليل من النجم على
مايورسكي للدفاع عنه من دون غطاء
للقوات ولا هياكل فقط غبار
قرية الطريق الصغيرة الكاملة المكاسب الأولى
للهجوم المضاد الكامل المتجدد لأوكرانيا
صغير جدًا ولكنه رمزي  حتى أن روسيا
زعمت يوم الاثنين أنها، من خلال القصف المستمر،
أخرجت أوكرانيا منها مرة أخرى، وهو
أمر يسخر منه هؤلاء الرجال الذين عادوا للتو من تلك
المعركة،
وهو ما يسمى علامة قاتلوا طوال الأيام العشرة
للهجوم حتى
فر الروس أخيرًا
هنا، وهو كالقذائف تحكم في
التقدم الأولي
عندما تهاجم تحت قصف العدو،
يقول إنه ليس لديك مكان للاختباء، وهذا هو
الجزء الأصعب، لقد حاولوا منذ ذلك الحين
الهجوم مرة أخرى مرتين بمجموعات صغيرة
وقاتل من أجل هنا أيضًا،
المدينة التي قبلها حيث
اختبأ الروس 200 جندي فيها.  الأقبية لا
تترك حتى للمرحاض لذلك
هاجمت أوكرانيا بقوة أصغر
يأخذنا إلى حيث اتخذ الروس
موقفهم الأخير قاعة المدرسة وممراتها
لا يوجد حب يقول الجدار
يبدو أنهم يستمتعون بالشيء الذي
أحضروه ولم يتركوا أي شيء  إن القرائن التي تفسر سبب
قتالهم،
أحد الأشياء التي يصعب على
الأوكرانيين فهمها هي السبب الذي يجعل
الروس يقاتلون بشدة من أجل
التدقيق هنا الآن والنصر الأخير الذي حققه
ستارمايورسكي على الطريق هو
أن هذه هي خطوط
دفاعهم الأخيرة، حسنًا، لا  يعتقدون أن هناك
المزيد من القتال الذي يتعين القيام به،
آمل أنه عندما نتجاوز
خط دفاعهم الأخير، يقول، ثم
يبدأون في الركض الآن، وما زالوا يشعرون أن هناك
شيئًا خلفهم،
نعم نشعر بالدعم ولكننا
متعبون جدًا
هناك  هناك الكثير في المستقبل
ربما تكون أوكرانيا قد وضعت احتياطياتها الآن
للقتال لكنهم يواجهون نفس
الوحشية الروسية
[موسيقى]
تكتيكاتهم لم تتغير يقول
إنهم يضعون المدانين العاصفة في المقدمة
دون أي اتصالات أو معلومات
ينتظرونها  الموت لا أفهم
دوافعهم أو ما الذي
يقاتلون من أجله
ريفا يحمل بندقية روسية جديدة من طراز ak-12
ككأس بينما يصف الغاز الذي استخدموه
عليه
[موسيقى]
كان هناك إطلاق نار فوضوي يقول
لمعرفة أين نحن  كان الغاز حينها
لا تشعر به، فهو يتحرك ببطء على طول
الأرض كنت أحزم حقيبتي عندما
شعرت بحرقة في حلقي وأنفي، لقد
اخترت
علامة نداء واحدة، قبو مشغول
بإخباري كيف بدأ الروس
المفخخة-  محاصرة العقول وهي تضع قنبلة يدوية
تحت لغم مضاد للدبابات عندما
تنقطع
أصوات النيران الصادرة التي تتحرك بشكل لا نهاية له تقريبًا،
لكن ليس متأكدًا من المدة التي سيستغرقها
السقوط